this is an article published by the
Guardian back in 2014 it's an obituary
for Australia's Great Barrier Reef
two years later outside magazine
published this it's another obituary for
the reef and more recently we got this
new and also the file the Great Barrier
Reef is a terminal stage have we really
killed the Great Barrier Reef the answer
is no but we sure are trying it'd be
hard to call the time of death for the
Great Barrier Reef because it's actually
some 3,000 reefs spread over an area the
size of Italy so there's plenty of room
right now for there to be widespread
damage and lots of relatively healthy
reefs that's something dive operators
there really want you to know the
contrasting colors I'm there and the
water and when the light hits the
different colors just sadness yes
absolutely but the world's coral reefs
including the Great Barrier Reef have
had a really hard time the past few
years after decades of degradation from
local threats like pollution and
overfishing coral reefs have now
undergone a record-breaking global
bleaching event that's when coral turns
white which puts them at a high risk of
dying it started in 2014 during the
Northern Hemisphere summer abnormally
warm water cost corals in Guam and the
Northern Mariana Islands to start
bleaching on mass by the end of 2014
corals around Hawaii Florida and the
Marshall Islands were bleaching too when
summer came around in the southern
hemisphere bleaching spread to coral
reefs in the South Pacific and Indian
Ocean and towards the end of 2015
corals throughout the Caribbean were
bleached to Hawaii squirrels bleach for
a second time by now El Nina was in full
force and when combined with global
warmin it kept sea temperatures high
enough to continue the bleaching event
into 2016
hitting corals in asia west coast of
Africa and the Great Barrier Reef - the
worst bleaching in fact that the Great
Barrier Reef had ever seen
we can continued into 2017 when the
Great Barrier Reef was hit again
Australia's Great Barrier Reef in grave
condition tonight for the second year in
a row this video showing the bleaching
two-thirds of the Great Barrier Reef has
now been devastated by severe coral
bleaching which is caused by rising
water temperatures researchers first
documented global coral bleaching in
1998 a record warm year and it happened
again in 2010 but this third coral
bleaching event is by far lower and
looking at this temperature trend you
can get why people are starting to say
goodbye to coral reefs but to really get
what makes them vulnerable you have to
understand how coral reefs work corals
are related to jellyfish and sea
anemones but you probably notice that
they don't look quite as squishy there's
a couple reasons for that
for one thing they live in colonies each
coral structure is made of hundreds or
thousands of individual coral animals
called polyps each of these little bumps
is where a polyp lives they're easy to
overlook if you're snorkeling but if you
look closely you can see them especially
at night when they're less likely to be
hiding those polyps build a skeleton
together
not all corals do this but the ones that
build reefs do so by creating a calcium
carbonate skeleton underneath them layer
by layer so the living polyps sit and
we'll cook on top of an ever expanding
skeleton structure which in turn sits on
top of the compacted skeletons of
previous corals from thousands of years
ago otherwise known as limestone by
building these structures with all these
nooks and crannies corals provide homes
for thousands of other animals and
plants an estimated 25% of all marine
species even though they take up less
than 1% of the ocean floor those reefs
provide billions of dollars worth of
economic value to people every year
through fisheries tourism and protection
from storm waves but here's the thing
corals can't build reefs on their own
coral reefs exists because of an
incredible partnership between animal
and plants that's because reef building
corals get the majority of their energy
and nutrients from single-celled algae
that live inside
the coral polyps it's where they get
their greenish brown color - they're
called Zoe's Aunt Polly and like other
plants they get their energy from
sunlight
that's why coral reefs mostly grow near
the surface of the ocean where the Sun
shines but this partnership breaks down
under heat stress after multiple weeks
of temperatures even just a couple of
degrees Celsius hotter than the maximum
temperatures that they're used to the
photosynthetic system in the algae
starts to accumulate reactive oxygen
molecules like hydrogen peroxide which
leak into the coral polyp cells to
protect themselves from damage the coral
polyps kick the algae out of their
bodies leaving the pale skeleton showing
through by warming up the planet we are
among many other things breaking up the
team that built the oceans most diverse
ecosystem
but bleached corals don't necessarily
die what happens next depends on how
severe and long-lasting the high
temperatures are when researchers assess
the damage to the Great Barrier Reef in
2016 they found that coral jet was
concentrated in the northern section of
the reef where bleaching had been the
most severe in the central section 33
percent of the rings' bleached severely
but there was only around 6 percent
mortality that's because those anthalie
can return to a coral colony within a
few weeks
if the water cools back down fast enough
if not the coral dies from starvation or
disease if enough coral colonies die a
reef can get taken over by fuzzy brown
seaweed some coral reefs have
transformed into this if there are
enough fish and other grazers to eat up
the seaweed new coral larvae can settle
there and the reefs can start building
up again after the 1998 bleaching the
corals of the Great Barrier Reef's
eventually recovered but it takes a
decade or more for even the fastest
growing corals to build back up and that
10-year time line assumes one very
important condition that they don't
bleach all over again and they almost
certainly will climate models projected
in the coming decades the conditions now
causing mass bleaching will become
increasingly frequent until eventually
they happen every summer how soon that
happens depends a lot on whether we
start cutting our greenhouse gas
emissions
if we don't annual bleaching conditions
are projected for parts of the Great
Barrier Reef by mid-century at that
point you coral reefs could survive if
we buy them more time by slowing down
global warming corals and there's those
vampa we may be able to acclimate or
eventually evolve to tolerate warmer
weather coral reefs would still change
and probably still shrink but we could
give them a better chance that's why it
doesn't make sense to pronounce them
instead this ecosystem is dynamic there
are forces building up that are battling
the forces carrying it down and those
factors vary by species and by location
but with global warming humans have
sided against the world's coral reefs to
an unprecedented
disagree some of that damage is now
unavoidable but the battle isn't over
and it's not too late for us to switch
sides if you'd like to learn more about
what climate change is doing to the
biodiversity of our planet go over to
audible.com slash box their massive
collection of audiobooks includes a lot
of titles about climate change including
the sixth extinction and unnatural
history this is a Pulitzer Prize winning
book by Elizabeth Kolbert covering not
just coral reefs but animals and plants
around the world that are struggling to
keep up with environmental change you
can sign up for a free 30-day trial at
audible.com slash box and if you decide
not to continue on with them you still
get to keep your book so sign up at
audible.com slash box and start spending
your commute or your cooking time or
your cleaning time learning more about
the role that our species is playing in
the history of life on Earth
[Music]